what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar back at it again with another how
strong is video thousands voted on our
Instagram at anime out drawer and the
results weren't even close this time we
were heating things up with the
brilliant star of the upcoming Demon
Slayer movie the flame pillar Georgia
row then Goku he is definitely one of
the manliest characters in demon slayer
and one of my favorites I said I'd get
started on this one as soon as the GU
video got over four thousand likes and
in blue past that in the first day so
let's make it a bit harder this time
around as soon as this video hits five
thousand likes that's right five
thousand I'll get started on the next
one ASAP and as usual you can vote for
what the next video will be via
Instagram stories link in the
description and in the pin comment below
make sure to follow us at anime uproar
because we have Volt's like these on a
regular basis if you haven't be sure to
subscribe to their channel and ring that
notification bell because you won't know
when a new video comes out if you don't
there will be manga spoilers in this
video we have to look at all of the
relevant evidence to determine how
stronger than Goku is after all now
without further ado let's jump into it
Georgia roaring Goku with his glorious
flaming lion looking hair is the son of
Sheen draw an angle coup the former
flame pillar so he definitely has some
talent in his genes but this is also
matched with some of the hardest work
you'll see his father has a completely
different view on things though then
Kuro does the father is envious that he
and his son do not possess the original
and strongest breath the breath of the
Sun he views all other breaths including
the breath of the flames as inferior
this inferiority complex along with the
death of his wife led him to view things
as pointless as he tells Kuro when he
becomes a pillar we won't ever become
great people anyways both you and me and
quote imagine that imagine working so
hard to accomplish something and instead
of your dad being proud of you he tells
you that all of your effort is pointless
and that you'll never be great this is
what Kyoto was dealing with and he was
mentally strong enough to not get
discouraged by his father's negativity
in fact he tells his little brother that
his father said it was all pointless but
he ensures his brother that his passion
won't die because of that the flames in
his heart will never disappear he will
never be the
hearten and he tells his little brother
that he has an older brother who
believes in him no matter what and
encourages him to do his best it almost
brings me to tears how awesome this guy
is so yes it's arguably true that Jojo
had a limit to how strong he could get
and that limit was below the first
breath of the Sun user and strongest
demon ser in history or Ichi but that
doesn't mean he couldn't do his best to
get as strong as possible rather than
focusing on what he couldn't change then
Goku focus on becoming as strong as he
possibly could and he became pretty dang
strong by the time the demon train ark
rolls around then Goku has reached an
extremely impressive level of power
compared to ton zero and his friends at
the time he's in a completely different
ballpark while he's sleeping on the
train a kid enters his dream and tries
to find and destroy his spiritual core
which lies in the unconsciousness area
the idea is that people are in the
center of their dreams and at the edge
of the dream is the unconsciousness area
the child immediately notices that in
Goku has one weird unconsciousness area
she starts sweating profusely because
it's so hot there it's the first time
the child ever saw red spiritual core
according to the girl then Goku has a
brittle core like glass that should be
easy to destroy but before she can
destroy it then Goku's real body moves
and takes the girl by the neck under
normal circumstances people can move
their bodies when they fall under the
techniques of a sleep demon but then
Goku is clearly not a normal case then
Goku's instinct is so sharp that he has
sensed the presence of the girl even
though she didn't give off a thirst for
blood in fact that n Goku could kill the
girl but he doesn't because he has no
reason to kill humans because the girl
is suffering in the real world
she came moving to dream so to stay in a
deadlock for a while eventually a
tengoku does wake up and he's ashamed
that as a pillar he fell under the
demons technique but he doesn't dwell on
this and quickly gets to work
the demon trade is made up of eight cars
with passengers in them then Goku tells
ton zero that he will protect five on
his own while sending to an ethical
together protect the other three then
Gokul gives himself the most difficult
task and since none zero any no escape
to kill the lower moon probably since
they could not manage the five cars by
the
selves what I'm about the station I'd be
taken too literally or seriously but
it's fun to consider then Goku currently
seems to be worth over threes any tools
at least in this situation since then
each who can cover roughly 1.5 cars by
himself and then Goku can cover at least
five by himself he's so quick that
hunter is shocked when he witnesses the
speed tension okay demon seed and Goku
because he's moving so fast
tonzura also can't help but be impressed
by how quickly then Goku grasped the
situation and came up with the best
strategy possible when lower Moon 1 and
mu is dying he can't help but blame it
and Goku and the strength of the pillars
despite the fact that the demon took 200
people as hostages then Goku was quick
enough to save every person in his 5
cars despite the fact that in Goku
arguably had the most impossible job he
seems completely fine when the battle is
over
it doesn't even look like he broke a
sweat it leaves me to believe that he
could have handled much more but he
wanted the others to get some valuable
experience after the battle with n mu
then goku seized on 0 and he can see
through him this appears to be the
see-through world that ton zero later
gains access to and then goq was able to
tell exactly what's happening in ton
zeros body and is able to guide him
through everything calmly when then goku
notices that ton zero succeeded in
stopping his blood he gives him more
encouragement he says and I quote you
can definitely get stronger compared to
how you were the day before a truly
awesome quote that we should all live by
we really get to see what they're in
Goku's got when upper Moon 3 occas
unexpectedly shows up Icaza can see it
in Goku strength just by looking at him
he immediately knows he's a hashira aka
a pillar according to a Quezada and Goku
developed his fighting spirit to the
edge of perfection akiza says that angle
is power will never truly reach
perfection because he's human
as a result akiza wants him to become a
demon so he can surpass that human limit
akiza says that if he becomes a demon he
can train for hundreds of years and keep
getting stronger
however then Goku argues that there's
more to life than strength he says that
I quote growing old and dying is what
gives meaning and beauty to the fleeting
span of a human life it's precisely
because we age and die that our lives
have value and nobility
strength is not a word that means much
in regards to the flesh
quote those are some truly profound gems
of wisdom from Anand Goku Icaza is
frustrated though precisely because when
goku is so strong he says that in goku
worked so hard to build such magnificent
talent that it's a shame to let it
wither away he decides that he'll kill
then goku while he's young and strong
when then goku decides to close the
distance between him and Icaza alcázar
calls her and goku speed amazing
then he comments on his wonderful sword
technique hundred Oh Annie knows K would
do nothing but get in the way if they
got involved at this point you know
Stephen says and I quote there's no
opening I can't get in I can't keep up
with their movements it's like they're
in another dimension I feel it if I get
too close there's only that I know that
if I go into help I'll only get it away
and quote keep in mind that enos K has
amazing animal-like instincts and so
this is especially accurate since it's
coming from him despite their spider
family adventured their recent training
and their fight against lower moon one
there's still nowhere close to a ten
Goku's level and then goku manages to
get a wonderful cut to use our castles
words on the upper moon however since
he's one of the most powerful demons in
existence he regenerates pretty quickly
and then Goku's wounds are different
though since he's human his left eye
broken ribs and internal bleeding won't
heal so easily a Kasai explains that
those serious wounds would be nothing
but scratches to a demon and he would
heal in the blink of an eye from them so
what is Haq is saying here while he's
suggesting that that n goku and him
would arguably be able to fight on equal
terms if they were both demons perhaps
when goku would even be able to
overwhelm him but since he's not he
can't akasa says that no matter how hard
they struggle humans cannot defeat
demons remember that quote because we
will be coming back to it later then
goku despite his injuries is undaunted
he says and i quote i will fulfill my
duty I won't let anyone here die and
quote thus that would be a victory for n
Goku if he succeeds in protecting
everyone present our causes surprised at
n Goku's fighting spirit even with
serious wounds then Goku is full of
determination and spiritual fortitude
his stance has no weakness again uh cuz
I insist that he should become a demon
so they could fight each other forever
then then Goku rushes in with an attack
and Acosta uses his move destructed
death annihilation type to
counter-attack when the smoke clears we
see that akiza's arm penetrated straight
through that in Goku's body doesn't in
Goku give up because he got this mortal
wound not a chance
he remembers that his mother called him
one of the chosen strong ones she taught
him that as a strong person he has a
duty to help people weaker than him
in the flashback his dying mother tells
him that she won't live long but she's
happy that she gave birth to such a
strong and kind child like it and Goku
we then cut back to then Goku as he cuts
in to act as a snack cuz I can't believe
that in Goku still has enough power to
swing a sword as in Goku thinks to
himself that the honor was his to have
been the child of such a great mother he
continues to push his sword into our
castles neck Icaza tries to punch it in
Goku but the ring Goku stops his arm
with his left hand
akka says once against surprise he can't
believe that angle was able to stop his
fist he calls her and Goku's power
unbelievable the flame pillar is able to
muster this much power even though his
guts have been pierced by a casus fist
our cousin notices that dawn is coming
he needs to hurry but he can't move his
arm and then Goku won't let him go I
don't think I need to point out how
unbelievably impressive it is that in
Goku has the strength to keep hold of
al-qasas arms against his will then Goku
gets about halfway through our kisses
neck with his sword the Sun is just
about out so it seems like rain Goku is
going to defeat Icaza
however Alcazar not being able to free
himself through any other means rips his
own arms off so that he can run away and
survive sure our Casas survives that n
goku dies eventually but our cause is
the one that ran away
furthermore and then goku succeeded in
protecting everyone there from a kazan
so in a way a human did manage to beat
the demon here or at the very least it
was not a clear win for the demon after
all Alcazar ran away before then goku
was dead he ran water and goku was still
trying to fight sure you can argue the
arkansas won the war although that
depends on how far into the story you
look but it seems like when goku
definitely won this battle as tangible
points out Icaza is a coward who runs
away even though demon Slayers are
always brave enough to fight demons on
their
terr ie in the nighttime according to
Tanja dough then Goku is stronger much
stronger than a casa because he saw the
fight through to the end
and protected everyone tonzura says the
defeat is a causes and the victory
belongs to then Goku and then Goku
smiles at this even though he's dying he
decides to focus on helping tan judo he
tells him to visit house when Goku where
he might be able to learn more about the
dance of the fire-god Pancho asks him if
there's any way for an Goku to stop the
bleeding and he says no he
matter-of-factly says that he's going to
die soon then he just keeps talking his
final thoughts are for others he asks
ton zero to tell his little brother
Sandro
to follow his heart and his bad to take
care of himself
finally he tells ton zero that he
believes in his little sister and
considers her to be a member of the
demon slayer core he tells them all to
stand tall and be proud he says and I
quote no matter how weak or unworthy you
feel keep your heart burning grit your
teeth and move forward if you just curl
up in a ball and hide time will pass you
by
it won't stop for you while you wallow
in grief and quote he tells them not to
worry about his death and it's normal
for a pillar to protect his juniors and
that he believes in them he sees his
mother who tells her and Goku that he
fulfilled his duty and used his gift
splendidly and he dies with a big smile
on his face after his death decided to
reveals that n Goku used a bunch of
techniques when the train went off the
tracks in order to minimize the damage
to the train cars he did that on top of
everything else when the sound pillar
hears the news I'm gonna go lose debt he
thinks that even then Goku lost to an
upper moon suggesting that he is strong
even among the pillars the snake pillar
straight up can't believe he lost which
further illustrates how highly people
viewed him it is normal for upper moons
who live for centuries to kill pillars
when the missed pillar mu Ichiro later
beats up her moon five we are told that
this is an unnatural situation so the
fact that someone can't believe that n
Goku lost to upper moon three means that
he had to be extremely strong even among
pillars when a much stronger tunnel ng
you fight aqus eye again later odd kazar
remarks and he's glad and goku died that
day he says and I quote he might not
have been able to grow any stronger
because
worthless values made him want to stay
human and quote so it is strongly
suggested by akka Saad Eddin Goku
reached his peak of power as a human
this is the beta Belov course especially
since his demon slayer mark hadn't
manifested yet but regardless let's
compare what we know about that and goku
to the peak of use power in the gear
video I set out compared to in this
video and I can do that because they
both fought the same opponent so let's
take a look at how G you fared when
compared to a 10 Goku for a moment Icaza
is interested in gives technique that
call make a law because he's never seen
it before
you also made just to cut off those arms
off while he's fighting taunted off but
they quickly reconnect he caused us or
technique developed and wonderful and he
asks for G's name then he sends GU
blasting off like Team Rocket with a
kick something he did not manage to do
with it and Goku the fact that akiza
managed to do this while he was
balancing fighting GU and hundred oh
definitely suggests that and Goku was
more powerful than this Q however this
version of GU quickly gets a power
upgrade in the form of a demon slayer
mark as he says senses that were closed
off to him awoke because he finally has
an opponent's strong enough to push him
to the limit so how would this upgraded
you fare when compared to it and Goku EU
speed increases but Alcazar quickly
adapts to a speed the fact is that
Alcazar compliments key much less
overall than he complimented on Goku and
he doesn't obsessively ask you to become
a demon something he seems to like doing
with strong opponents furthermore he
remarks how he can barely cut Icaza and
how when he does cut Akasa it's too
shallow
keep in mind Q also has a strong pungent
off helping him during the fight while
attained Goku had no help and arguably
still managed to do better than you
ah cos a punches gu sword breaking it it
then seems like he is about to kill him
before tangelo comes to the rescue with
his new ope non self state and cuts off
a causes arm
do you even admits that punch will save
him then Icaza uses a move that tension
can dodge but Ghia cannot and his dead
calm ability doesn't work against it
either
what's more åkesson ever used the move
that gave it an Goku a mortal wound
against GU and tan zero rather he used
it on himself in an attempt to kill
himself after
regains his human memories thus to me
all of this suggests that n Goku with no
mark was stronger than GU with a demon
slayer mark Mingo ku had no help and he
was able to put up a better fight yes he
had the help of the Sun coming up which
helped free karakasa but even if we take
that into account he still did
impressively well how cuz I never broke
his sword by punching it and he couldn't
just finish him off as he was about to
do with you I cuz I truly struggled with
it and Goku and the truth is he did not
really struggle with you despite the
fact that you had conjured us help
Tundra is the one who arguably reached a
power stronger than in Goku's for a
brief period of time
he couldn't maintain it for long but
while he was in that non-self state he
was able to cut off axis head even after
warning him that he was coming Octus I
was looking at him he knew he was coming
and he still couldn't stop dodging those
attack so it's not like tensioner just
got a lucky hit because he had no
fighting spirit
he was also too fast for Arkansas to
dodge and strong enough to cut through
his tough neck in one go
something gu and then goku couldn't do
therefore I would put non self state on
[ __ ] or above and Goku in strength but
it is important to keep in mind that n
Goku didn't have a demon slayer mark yet
so there's no telling how much that
would have boosted his power
Yomi is acknowledged to be the strongest
pillar so he has to be stronger than
than Goku was when he died but as far as
the rest go I'd say it in Goku was close
to second along with Muccino and sana me
the trouble is that we never get to see
him fight with a mark and because of
that we can't comfortably put him above
mark Muccino and mark
sana me still though I would no doubt
put him in the top half of the pillars
it is made clear that even among pillars
he was extremely strong what he
accomplished against akazawa stata mark
was nothing short of miraculous
however as oft as i pointed out he
probably was close to his limit as a
human while people like kanji doll
arguably a breath of the sun' user still
have a long way to go
then Goku's father might have been right
that the breath of the flame users can
get as strong as the breath of the Sun
users some people are more talented than
others even so that doesn't mean that in
Goku should have given up then Goku
strive to live up to his own
full potential according to a casa he
got ridiculously close to that and in
the process he ended up becoming one of
the strongest pillars because he didn't
give up and committed to doing his best
he was able to save tons IDO who is
arguably more talented but was weaker at
the time due to his lack of experience
thus it's thanks to Dan Goku that hunter
lived long enough to eventually surpass
his strength then Goku's efforts weren't
a waste
he saved hundred or in us case and two
and a Zuko and they will no doubt be
instrumental for eventually defeating
Mouzon then Goku's legacy lives on as
long as the people he saved and
influenced do and that is it for this
video I am blown away by how awesome
didn't go who is yeah he's strong but
more importantly his character is
absolutely amazing he's such a great guy
and he died in the most manly way
possible I seriously believe that then
Goku will continue to inspire me for the
rest of my life that is how much this
firebender impressed me if you enjoyed
this video make sure to smash that like
button to let me know
remember if we can get 5,000 likes I'll
get started on the next how strong is
video ASAP as usual you can vote for
what the next video will be via
Instagram stories link in the
description and in the pin comment below
make sure you are following us at anime
uproar because we have these votes on a
regular basis if you haven't be sure to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
notification bell because you won't know
when the next video comes out if you
don't a big thank you goes to our
patrons over on patreon who help make
videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro here to
your patrons the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King
Cyrus angel Cruz Steelers poet Pablo
atropos Wraith fit edala beat a Karachi
and Anatoly Cassatt's ki DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stay on top all
clans Stephen and Radha
Aloha I am Maddy Mac 239 makoto-kun and
ya boy Seth if you enjoy our work you
can support more by going over to
patreon calm an Emir or and becoming a
patron today for as little as $1 if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord so check out patreon and we are
dror link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer no matter what way you
choose to support us you'll get the same
great benefits thanks again for
everything and until next time see you
space Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]